JACQUI: ALL RIGHT.
BILL MELUGIN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
IS.
GRIFF: FOR MORE, JOINING US NOW
FORMER ACTING SECRETARY FOR THE
DHS, CHAD WOLF.
MR. SECRETARY, THANK YOU FOR
TAKING TIME AND WHAT A PERFECT
GUEST TO TALK ABOUT WHAT WE JUST
HEARD FROM OUR GREAT REPORTER,
BILL MELUGIN, DOWN THERE.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE 650
MIGRANTS STOPPED, MANY OF THEM
CHILDREN.
AND I CAN’T HELP BUT THINK IT’S
INTERESTING THAT IT COINCIDED ON
THE SAME DAY THAT YOUR
COUNTERPART, SECRETARY MAYORKAS,
AND SECRETARY BLINK WERE IN
MEXICO TALKING ABOUT --
SECRETARY BLINKEN WERE IN MEXICO
TALKING ABOUT BORDER SECURITY
ISSUES.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> THE ISSUE WE SAW WITH
HUNDREDS OF MIGRANTS IN THOSE
TRACTOR-TRAILER TRUCKS IS,
AGAIN, ANOTHER SYMPTOM OF THIS
VERY INHUMANE IMMIGRATION AND
BORDER POLICY THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS.
AGAIN, THEY DON’T WANT TO TALK
CONCERN YOU DON’T SEE OFFICIALS
OR THE SECRETARY OR ANY OTHER
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL TALKING
ABOUT THAT TYPE OF SEIZURE AND
THE PAIN AND THE DANGEROUS
JOURNEY THAT THOSE MIGRANTS ARE
BEING PUT THROUGH.
BUT THEY’RE DOING THAT BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THAT THE U.S. BORDER
IS OPEN.
AND SO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS SENDING THEM THE SIGNAL TO
TAKE THAT DANGEROUS JOURNEY, AND
I THINK THAT’S WRONG.
IT CERTAINLY NEEDS TO CHANGE.
LOOK, WHETHER YOU HAVE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, THE DHS
SECRETARY AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL DOWN THERE IN MEXICO
TALKING ABOUT HOPEFULLY SECURITY
AND BORDER SECURITY, BUT I
NOTICE THAT THEY’RE ALSO TALKING
ABOUT A WHOLE HOST OF OTHER
ISSUES, THESE ARE TALKS THAT
HAPPEN IN ANY ADMINISTRATION
THAT HAPPEN ALL THE TIME.
THE QUESTION THOUGH IS WHAT IS
CHANGING ON THAT BORDER AS A
RESULT OF THOSE TALKS.
WHAT IS CHANGING ON THE
ENFORCEMENT POSTURE BOTH IN THE
U.S. AND ON THE MEXICO SIDE.
AND I DON’T THINK THAT WE’RE
SEEING ANY DIFFERENCES.
WE’RE CERTAINLY NOT SEEING ANY
CONCRETE ACTIONS THAT THEY’RE
TAKING AS A RESULT OF THOSE
TALKS.
GRIFF: WELL, THAT’S WHY I WAS SO
EXCITED TO SPEAK WITH YOU
BECAUSE WHAT SPECIFICALLY IF YOU
WERE IN SECRETARY MAYORKAS’
CHAIR IN MEXICO, WHAT WOULD YOU
ASK MEXICO FOR?
I JUST GOT BACK FROM THE MEXICAN
SOUTHERN BORDER AND PORTRAYED
HOW OPEN THAT IS.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY BEING FLOODED,
AND I’M GOING TO GET ON A PLANE
IN A FEW HOURS AND GO TO PANAMA
WHERE THERE ARE TENSES OF
THOUSANDS OF HAITIANS -- TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF HAITIANS ON THEIR
WAY NOW.
SO TO BE CONSTRUCTIVE, WHAT CAN
MEXICO DO?
WHAT SHOULD THE U.S. BE ASKING
FOR?
>> WELL, THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT
CAN DO A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
THINGS.
THEY CAN CLOSE THEIR SOUTHERN
BORDER DOWN TO THAT ILLEGAL
MIGRATION THAT WE SEE.
IT’S NOT EASY FOR THEM.
THEY DON’T HAVE THE SAME
RESOURCES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT THE U.S. HAS, BUT IT IS
DOABLE.
THEY CAN DEPLOY THEIR GIVE LENT
OF THE NATIONAL GUARD TO STOP
INDIVIDUALS COMING ACROSS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER THAT DON’T HAVE
THE CORRECT PAPERWORK.
THEY CAN SHUT THAT DOWN.
THEY HAVE A NUMBER OF OTHER
BORDER CHECKPOINTS WITHIN THE
INTERIOR OF MEXICO.
THEY NEED TO BE PROPERLY
STAFFED, BUT YOU NEED TO ENFORCE
IT.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN WE’VE SEEN
AND HEARD OF REPORTS WHERE
MIGRANTS COME THROUGH THESE
BORDER CHECKPOINTS OR OTHER
CHECKPOINTS, THEY DON’T HAVE THE
RIGHT PAPERWORK, AND YET THEY
CONTINUE ON THEIR JOURNEY.
THEY NEED TO START FLYING OR
REPATRIATING FOLKS FROM MEXICO
BACK TO CENTRAL AMERICA, BACK TO
SOUTH AMERICA, BACK TO HAITI
THE, BACK TO ALL THE COUNTRIES
THAT THEY’RE PICKING UP.
THEY NOT ONLY NEED TO STOP THEM,
APPREHEND THEM AND DETAIN THEM
IF THEY HAVE NO LEGAL RIGHT TO
BE IN MEXICO, BUT THEY NEED TO
REMOVE THEM BACK TO THEIR HOME
COUNTRIES INSTEAD OF SIMPLY
RELEASING THEM FOR THEM TO
CONTINUE ON TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
GRIFF: I WANT TO GET YOUR
REACTION, BILL MELUGIN ALLUDED
TO IT, I RETWEETED VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS’ VIDEO SHE PUT
OUT OF VISITING A DAY SCHOOL,
VISITING WITH THESE SCHOOL
CHILDREN LITERALLY, CHAD,
PLAYING BINGO WITH THEM ON THE
DAY THAT BLINKEN, MAYORKAS AND
MERRICK GARLAND ARE DOWN IN
MEXICO TRYING TO SOLVE THE
CRISIS.
YOUR REACTION.
>> WELL, AGAIN, IT’S QUITE
UNBELIEVABLE THAT YOU HAVE THE
BORDER CZAR WHO IS IN CHARGE OF
SHE SAYS NOT BORDER SECURITY,
BUT SHE’S TALKING ABOUT THE ROOT
CAUSES OF MIGRATION, THAT’S WHAT
THIS TEAM WAS DOING IN MEXICO,
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THOSE ROOT
CAUSES, MEETING WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF MEXICO.
SO IT’S CERTAINLY AT THE VICE
PRESIDENT’S LEVEL TO BE DOWN
THERE TO BE ENGAGED ON THESE
DISCUSSIONS, AND SHE’S
COMPLETELY ABSENT.
SHE’S ABSENT FROM ANY FOLLOW-UP
TO HER PREVIOUS VISIT TO
GUATEMALA AND THEN TO MEXICO BUT
ALSO FROM THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
SHE’S BEEN TO EL PASO WHICH HAS
NOT SEEN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE ILLEGAL CROSSINGS.
YOU KNOW, WE NEED LEADERSHIP,
AND WE NEED LEADERSHIP FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE WHICH IS LACK ARING
AND FROM THE DEPARTMENT WHICH IS
LACKING.
AND I THINK THAT’S WHY YOU
CONTINUE TO SEE THE SAME FAILED
BORDER POLICIES MONTH IN AND
MONTH OUT WHICH IS DELIVERING
THE SAME RESULTS.
GRIFF GREFE YOU TALK ABOUT
LEADERSHIP, MR. SECRETARY, HOW
CAN THEY GET THIS URN CONTROL,
AND TELL ME HOW THIS ENDS.
>> WELL, I THINK THERE’S VERY
SPECIFIC THINGS THAT THEY CAN
DO.
AGAIN, WE LEFT THEM AD ROAD MAP
ON INITIATIVES AND POLICIES THAT
WORK WHETHER IT’S THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO AGREEMENT, UNFORTUNATELY
JUST LAST NIGHT WHICH WE HEARD,
YOU KNOW, CANCELING BORDER WALL
CONTRACTS.
IN THE RGV, IN THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY THERE IN TEXAS, WHICH IS
GROUND ZERO FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE ILLEGAL
APPREHENSIONS.
SO IN THE MIDST OF A 21-YEAR
CRISIS, THEY DECIDE TO CANCEL
BORDER WALL CONTRACTS.
THEY DECIDE TO CHANGE I.C.E.
GUIDELINES AS THEY DID LAST WEEK
WHERE YOU’RE NOT ABLE TO REMOVE
INDIVIDUALS FROM THE INTERIOR OF
THE COUNTRY IF THEY GET PAST THE
BORDER PATROL.
SO, AGAIN, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS CARRYING OUT
AN AGENDA THAT IS NOT
PRO-ENFORCEMENT, THAT IS NOT THE
RULE OF LAW.
THEY CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT
INITIATIVES THAT CONTINUE TO
ALLOW AND ATTRACT INDIVIDUALS TO
THE BORDER.
GRIFF: IT SURE DOESN’T SEEM LIKE